since you guys really enjoyed the last
reaction video and it was a genuinely
wild experience because of how insanely
absurd the lists were i thought it would
be fun to look at episode rankings and
again we can start with ign and also
before i go through i'm going to predict
that the battle of the bastards and the
winds of winter episodes from season six
are probably going to be in like the top
five of every list because of how
everyone loves them and their like
popular opinions also i won't look at
every single spot on these lists and
will only stop if something's out of the
ordinary kiss by fire at 21 really that
seems very low i think i had it
originally at number five on my personal
list but like you have one of the best
scenes in the show like the best
dialogue scene being the bath scene with
jaime not to mention the handful of
other great scenes that accompany that
bath scene i feel like kiss my fire is
like a consistently really good episode
so it's already really low fire and
blood too slow the watch was on the wall
at 14
whoa
okay uh
ign i thought the washers on the wall
was one of the best battle episodes
the action is outstanding the
cinematography thoroughly elevates it
with crazy wonders like when that shot
sweeps around the castle showing like a
360 of all the action so many characters
that you care so much about surviving
and even the dialogue scenes before the
battle are absolute bangers like with
maester ayman talking to samuel about
his past love
so to me the watches on the wall is an
absolute banger throughout and it's kind
of crazy that i guess they're listing
this as the worst battle episode so yeah
and then the door
they put the door at number 10. like if
you're just looking at the door from
their perspective of season six then i
could see why you loved this episode so
much but
given that
the horde of revelation means absolutely
nothing in season seven and eight it
really deteriorates the quality of this
episode and like overall twist not to
mention that there's really no other
good scenes in this episode besides this
revelation that occurs the only other
decent one is with canvara like the
acting is really good there but it has
really no like plot relevance and then
the rest of the scenes are just pretty
mediocre i don't need to list through
them so the fact that this is beating so
many other like season one great
episodes is kind of wild to me so it's
already off to a bad start in my opinion
and then number nine the mountain and
the viper to me this is pretty much fine
it was kind of close to cracking my top
ten there wasn't any other scenes within
this episode besides the ending that
really like wowed me and then the winds
of winter at number eight at least it's
not like number one they're kind of
putting it modestly kind of low i still
wouldn't put it on my list because
there's still a lot of bad scenes or
dumb scenes like with littlefinger
talking to sansa and sansa still
trusting him for whatever reason sansa
talking to jon snow and jon snow
thanking her when it was almost like she
was the reason why they lost the battle
because she was holding everyone back
and arya like spontaneously teleporting
to the twins and letting jamie go for
whatever reason despite the light of the
seven like 20 minute sequence being like
one of the best scenes in the show i
think the winds of winter is primarily
just like payoff inducing dopamine
that inherently drives people to like
the episode more but i don't hate it as
much as other people there's just some
scenes that bring the episode down in my
opinion then the battle of the bastards
i don't know the battle the bastards
episode is probably to me one of their
worst not because of this the battle of
the bastards but because of the like
siege of marine being so horrendous
i feel like people just forget about the
situ marine like yeah that happens the
atrocious plan of the masters trying to
assault marine against the second sons
the unsullied even having dragons that
can just eviscerate their fleet is so
dumb like two seasons of buildup for
this moment was horrendous
who would like this and then the battle
of the bastards isn't without flaws
either like there's lots of plot armor
by far the worst aspect is the sansa
riding and that's like a deus ex machina
saving the day so despite the battle the
bastards being technically and visually
very impressive
i think it's held back again by a lot of
issues that comes with season six
episodes number six the children season
four i think it's a really good episode
but there's two scenes in particular
that i think drag it down that being
bran getting jumped by whites and how
wonky and weird that scene was jojen
just spontaneously dying out of nowhere
and then despite brand and the hound's
fight scene being conceptually really
cool i think the editing was just
terrible and it was cut to crap and you
could barely tell it was happening
and it's more like this headache
inducing season one episode nine baylor
obviously we know why that's there
blackwater i put this at number two uh
to me to set my second favorite battle
sequence so i think that's a really good
placement and then the spoils of war
over wait the spoils of war over black
water and the watches on the wall oh no
oh boy okay so the thing with black
water and the washers on the wall is
that it's an entire episode that is
spent in that one area and even with
like with the black water all the
dialogue scenes leading up to the battle
are absolutely riveting and are really
good but for spoils of the war similar
to the battle of the bastards you have
to account for all the prior scenes too
because in season 7 most of the dialogue
scenes in comparison to the earlier
seasons are like no match like they have
they come nowhere close and there's even
a pretty bad scene where bran just eats
mira out of the show so
yeah but even like the actual battle
sequence despite it being really cool
and visually impressive it has probably
or arguably one of the dumbest moments
in any battle sequence where jaime just
gets spontaneously saved by brawn let
alone jaime doing that in the first
place was such an idiotic idea and it
was just flat out suicidal i don't know
what his plan was so if anything i would
probably put spoils of war at the bottom
of the battle episodes the reigns of
cast me a really good pick i would
absolutely agree and then hard home over
the reigns of castamere so according to
ign hardem is both the best battle
episode and the best episode just
overall have they seen the rest of the
episode
from
tyrion talking to daenerys and how easy
it was to get into her councilship more
boring scenes with gilly and sam arya's
coma inducing narrative that puts
absolutely everyone to sleep and then
like looking at hardham itself i
wouldn't even say it's the best battle
it's really good but it's primarily just
chaotic and like fastly edited i don't
want to like knock hard on because it's
pretty good it's just i'd prefer more
coherent action than fastly edited
action but at the end of the day this is
ign's opinion and i completely disagree
with the list
but at least it's not a bad episode
per se
it's kind of weird to me that they put
like my two least favorite battle
episodes in the top three that's kind of
just wild but whatever let's move on
next we have vulture oh they rank to
every episode so i'll just run through
this and stop wherever there's a wait so
wait the prince of winterfell at 72 this
is a season two episode let alone the
one of the most iconic tyrion lannister
scenes where he tells cersei that her
joy will turn to ashes in her mouth is
in this episode how is this episode
worse since season eight and seven and
looking over here is like season four
episodes too this is gonna be a while to
get through this i'll just probably skim
through it but i'm just curious to see
their reasoning here the answer to these
questions and more are not in this
episode which is a pure placeholder
before the battle of blackwater
apparently this person has never heard
of character developments and they just
care about plot development i guess it's
a terrible take terrible absolutely
rancid i'm just scrolling through this
when there's just so many like first
four season episodes just thrown in here
another season two the pointy ends
the last like five episodes of season
one are like all bangers what
you wonder he died at 48. oh but and
even the loss of gods and men tyrion's
trial what is this person smoking
i
this is almost worse than the character
rankings the climb
i need
oh it's gonna take me like years to get
through this apparently the last of the
starks one of the worst episodes in the
entire show is better
than so many great episodes the watchers
on the wall 21 no
i think this is the first battle episode
i've seen
why is ign and vulture art do people not
like the watches on the wall am i the
only one here i
i i i have no words
the iron
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
is this troll arguably i would say the
worst episode in the show this finale is
determined to give each of the main
characters an ending that suits them
excuse me uh yes bran becoming king
because it's he has a great story is a
great ending for his character i love
that i'd much prefer the winds of winter
being in the top 10 in the iron throne
all right let's just say we started at
number 10
and we didn't see the atrocity that was
above this oh never mind they can't
redeem themselves the long nights in
here too
what
no
my eyes are actually tearing up this is
really bad i'm already getting allergies
from these lists i'm only this is my
second list i'm looking at i didn't
think this would be as bad as the
character rankings i forgot this was
even a battle episode when i was talking
about past battle episodes to be honest
but yeah this is easily the worst i'm
high if i thought spells of war was the
worst battle episode because you can't
even see the battle episode oh
and then another season 8 episode i mean
to be fair know the seven kingdoms is
the best season 8 episode but comes
nowhere close to any other
like first four seasons like there's a
couple good dialogue scenes but then
that's contrasted immediately by like
really dumb moments where tormund just
becomes a comedic relief character
drinking just chugging giant smoke in
front of everyone they just butchered
him baylor all right good
congratulations you put a good episode
into your top 10 list
hard home i'd honestly take it at this
point
kiss by fire oh
it's it's getting better
the rains are casting here they're
coming back battle the bastards of
course it's this high i feel like
everyone's like contractually obligated
to put battle of the bastards within
their top ten or top five at this point
blackwater a good pick that's that's
even where i put my blackwater episode
the bells
i feel like i'm just blocking susie out
of my memory because this is also
technically a battle episode too why
would you even like this episode just
the vfx of dragons making explosions is
that why it's a good episode you have
one of the stupidest moments where
daenerys turns into a homicidal maniac
after winning the war where simply doing
nothing she would have just been fine
and would have been a beloved ruler oh
my god this is making me ill
okay i can't take this seriously i'm
just gonna move on let's look at
looper's 30 best game of thrones
episodes ranked
okay why is season seven already in top
thirty here by default you're saying
that season seven episodes are better in
general than the first four seasons but
all right let's keep going kiss by fire
really low it's either like they have
kissed by fire in the 20s or in like the
top five same thing with ig and i think
they put it at 21 but like what's the
dislike about this episode why are
people putting it so low
you winry die like these are all
contenders for my top 10. you win or die
i think i put in my top 10. how is the
dragon and the wolf better am i just in
the jurassic minority or is every list
i've looked at so far atrocious what is
even a good scene in dragon and the wolf
the whole meeting between all these
characters was just dumb and pointless
because the plan inherently to convince
cersei to help everyone was such a brain
dead plan from tyrion and then tyrion
and cersei meeting is so contrived
because she just doesn't kill him even
though she wants to littlefinger turns
into a dumb child like i could just keep
going on i'm just getting a headache at
this point beyond the wall that's not
even i that's again one of the worst
episodes can we get a good list please
spoil of course the spoilers and the
queen's justice
every the entirety of the season seven
is in here
of course the watchers on the wall it's
getting a bit never mind i was gonna say
it's getting better
if we just went from and now this watch
has ended in the line in the rows to
attain the seven kingdoms you honestly
can't tell me that that episode's better
everyone's just wowed by the scene where
brienne gets knighted oh boy that makes
it a top 10 contender baby
winter is coming why is episode 1 in
here
like don't get me wrong season one is
really good but an episode is primarily
just setting up things and setting up
characters it's not exactly like the
best episode but at least a season seven
episode's not in its place i guess
fire and blood good pick i'll take
battle the bastards at this point over
anything else i've been seeing the
reigns of kassamir okay the children
again i disagree baylor okay honestly
this is not a bad top 10 list blackwater
good hard home again i kind of disagree
with that notion and then the ones in
winter yeah of course so
yeah 10 and 9 being very questionable
picks just eat those out of the list and
honestly we don't have a bad top 10 but
a top 30 list is a is like a war crime
why why is beyond the wall in the top 20
okay all right yeah i think we'll just
end it there i was gonna look at a
buzzfeed article top ten list but
after going through these last three
lists i didn't expect them to be this
bad and i i just don't have the heart or
willpower to go through a buzzfeed top
10 list so i think we'll call it here
thank you for watching and let me know
if i'm just losing my mind in the
comments